near this house at fourth and growth
there's an intersection I encounter it
every day for 20 years now I'm stood
there pushing the little crosswalk
signal button and after pushing it I
stand there and stand there and stay in
there waiting for the light to change
and the longer I wait the more I push
the button over time I've tried
variations pushing it in a syncopated
rhythm pushing it at a certain amount of
times 7 13 29 sometimes I thought it was
dependent on the time of day or season
or some complex citywide pattern known
to only a select few through doll for
four years now I stood there trusting in
some invisible traffic signal logic
until today today I brought a crowbar
and after i reamed it from the post and
screwed the plating back and I looked
inside nothing not a single wire just a
lonely button attached to nothing but
the finger of a stupid pedestrian filled
with hope and trust I thought you should
know this and I take great pleasure and
what I'm about to say I do it all the
years all the times I stood out there
and push that button until my finger 8 I
knew it we demand the illusion of
involvement just give us a button that's
all we ask because as long as we have a
button to push we assume that we're
making things happen but the truth is
the light changes gonna wants to
we have nothing to do with it